- So I know people probably
bring this song up a lot,
but I just love it cause I
feel like it pertains to me,
but All About That Bass
was kind of your first
big, huge song and it's very body positive
and I feel like you like
a body positive anthem,
I feel like we're kind of similar in that,
what's your favorite right now?
There's so many.
- Oh man.
There are so many, like nowadays.
That was my thing with
All About That Bass,
I wrote it cause I didn't
have one growing up,
like obviously there were some out there,
but I didn't have like a special one.
But nowadays, man.
- Isn't that crazy, though
and now the song that you wrote
is that for so many people.
- Yeah, and I wrote it like
not thinking that anyone would hear it,
so I really wrote it like,
I wish I thought like this.
Then I saw how it affected
everyone and was like
oh the world need this?
Oh, let' do eight of
these, let' keep going.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah agreed.
Speaking of new music, I'm very excited.
I know you have a new album
coming out, Treat Myself,
which I love the album.
I think it's amazing,
but it also has a lot of female
empowerment songs, right?
- Yes, it does.
I have like three and one
is very special to me.
It's called Workin' on
It cause the hardest part
I think, about today,
especially with social media,
you know how everyone is
just like just be confident,
that's the worst thing
that I've ever heard
cause it's so hard to be confident,
it's so hard to turn
it on and be confident
and I wrote this one
song with my two girls,
it's about how when
someone compliments you
and you're like stop it.
You know how we all do that?
We're like ew, what do you
mean, and I'm working on it.
It's called Working on It and it's about
I'm gonna start to try
to be more confident
and start to love myself
and start to hear comments and
be like yeah, you're right.
- Accept it?
- Yeah, I think that's the hardest part.
- That's like the best thing
that anybody ever told me,
cause I'm super self deprecating
and it was the best thing
that people were like
it's funny, but at the end of the day,
take the compliment.
- Like, take this.
- We want to compliment you.
So it's really nice.
- Yes and today when I was
glammin' up for three hours,
looking at myself, I was like
am I the prettiest girl ever?
I would start saying that as
a joke and now I believe it.
I'm like I'm a doll, I'm adorable.
So if you say it, if you say it out loud,
your brain starts to believe it.
- I always call my hair and
makeup team Harry Potter
cause I walk in so different
and I walk out and I'm
like whose this babe?
Like what?
- People don't want to take pics with me
and I'm like I get it.
It's like three hours.
- My husband's confused, he
feels like he's cheating on me
cause it's like a
completely different human.
- Who is this?
- Speaking of husbands, you're a newlywed.
How's it going?
- Look at him, he's so cute.
- How is it?
Marriage is hard, but it's fun.
- No, not yet.
It's not hard, it's so perfect.
- That's because you're a newlywed,
you'll get there.
- Everyone's like you're a first year.
I'm like yeah, it's fresh and perfect
and everyday is better.
I got a foot massage last night,
he woke me up and got my favorite coffee,
it was in the fridge,
he's a different kind of species though.
- No that's my husband,
he literally gave me a foot
massage the other night,
my feet were killing me.
- We're twins.
- And he woke me up with
coffee, I tweeted about it.
- Dude, no way!
- Yes.
- I didn't even see that.
- We got good ones.
- We did, yeah.
We lucked out.
Very special.
- You also sing together, right?
He sings on some of your songs?
- I mean, yeah.
He does, they all do.
- I love you.
- I make them all sing
cause I don't have time
to go out and get a choir,
so they're my choir and they're so good
and for an audition
yesterday, he actually sang
an entire cover of a song
and we were all laughing
cause it was like really good.
And I did his backgrounds,
so we're cute, yeah.
- I love it.
I did hear a song and I'm bringing this up
because I feel like I have the
worst ugly cry in the world,
but I hear that you wrote a song
called Ugly Cry about Daryl.
- Yeah, he's only cried like three times
in our relationship,
but when it happens it's
so tough to look at.
It's also like we're
fighting and I'm like,
really you're just gonna
cry it out right now?
But his face gets like this
whole different type of human
being that I'm like what is that?
- Mine is I wanna believe
it looks like Rachel
McAdams from the Notebook.
- Yes.
- But it doesn't.
- It doesn't.
- It looks like Mommy Dearest
at the worst point in the movie.
It's just bad.
- So I wrote a song the
day after that and was like
you look ugly when you
cry, ugly when you cry
and it was like I recorded it
and he was like nice.
- You have a solid relationship
when she can write song called that.
- [Meghan] Yeah, he loved it.
He was like this is a great song.
- I love it.
I love that y'all love working together.
All right, can I see your ugly cry?
Oh my God, he did it.
He did it.
- Like, the mouth.
- I don't know if that's
it, but it's pretty ugly.
- It's bad, it's bad.
- I was like hey, when you cry on camera
for like movies and
stuff, don't do that one.
I was discussing it with
him, let's find a pretty cry.
- You're like my husband
and I am like Daryl.
- Yes, we're very reverse.
- Cause I am the one
who will start crying.
- But I love you.
- Love you too.
- [Kelly] Together you complete me.